so we've been talking about all the work
I do there's a story about
how it happens you know where do ideas
come from and that's an interesting
story where do I just come from so I I
had mentioned veniver Bush and
uh he wrote a really influential thing
called the endless Frontier so uh
science won World War II the the the the
more known story is nuclear bombs the
less well-known story is the rad lab so
at MIT an amazing group of people
invented radar which is really credited
as winning the war so after the war uh
grand old man from MIT and it's
um uh was charged with science on the
war how do we maintain that edge and the
report he wrote led to the National
Science Foundation and the modern notion
we take for granted but didn't really
exist before then of Public Funding of
research or research agencies
in it he made again what I consider an
important mistake which is he described
basic research leads to applied research
search leads to Applications leads to
commercialization leads to impact and so
we need to invest in that pipeline
the reason I considered a mistake
is almost all of the examples we've been
talking about
in my lab went backwards that the basic
research came from applications
and further almost all of the examples
we've been talking about came
fundamentally from mistakes so yeah
essentially everything I've ever worked
on has failed
but in failing something better happened
so the way I like to describe it is
ready aim fire is you do your homework
you aim carefully at something a Target
you want to accomplish and if everything
goes right you then hit the target and
succeed
what I do you can think of is ready fire
Aim so you you do a lot of work to get
ready
then you close your eyes and you don't
really think about where you're aiming
but you look very carefully at where you
didn't
you aim after you fire
and the the reason that's so important
is it if you do Ready Aim Fire there's
the best you can hope is hit what you
aim at so let me give you some examples
uh because this is a source of great
full of good lines today source of great
frustration so I mentioned the early
Quantum Computing so Quantum Computing
is this power of using quantum mechanics
to make computers that for some problems
are dramatically more powerful than
classical computers
before it started there was a really
interesting group of people who knew a
lot about
um physics and computing
that were inventing what became Quantum
Computing before it was clear anything
there was an opportunity there it was
just studying how those relate
here's how it fits to the ready fire aim
in the I was doing really short-term
work in my lab on shoplifting tags
on this was really before there was
Modern RFID and so how you put tags in
objects to sense them
something we just take for granted
commercially and there was a problem of
how you can sense multiple objects at
the same time
and so I was studying how you can
remotely sense materials to make
low-cost tags that could let you
distinguish multiple objects
simultaneously to do that you need
non-linearity so that the signal is
modulated
and so I was looking for materials
sources of non-linearity and that led me
to look at how nuclear spins interact
just just for for
um spin resonance this is the sort of
things you use when you let go in an MRI
machine
and so I was studying how to use that
and it turns out that it was a bad idea
you couldn't remotely use it for
um shoplifting tags
but I realized you could compute and so
um with a group of
colleagues thinking about early Quantum
Computing like David divincenzo and
Charlie Bennett was articulating what
are the properties you need to compute
and then looking at how to make the tags
turns out the tags were a terrible idea
for
um sensing
objects in a supermarket checkout but I
realized they were Computing so with Ike
Trang and a few other people we realized
we could program nuclear spins to
compute and so that's what we use to do
Grover's search algorithm and then it
was used for a shortest factoring
algorithm and it worked out the systems
we did it in nuclear magnetic resonance
don't scale Beyond a few qubits but the
techniques have lived on and so you know
all the current Quantum Computing
techniques grew out of the ways we would
talk to these spins but I'm telling this
whole story because it it came from a
bad way to make a shoplifting tag
starting with an application mistakes
led to the fundamental science
fundamental science yeah I mean can you
can you just link on that I mean just
just in using nuclear pens to do
computation that like
what gave you the guts to try to think
through this the from a fabric from a
digital fabrication perspective actually
how to LEAP from one to the other yeah I
wouldn't call it guts I would call it
collaboration so I so at IBM there was
this amazing group of like I mentioned
Charlie Bennett and David divincenzo and
Ralph Landau and Nabil Amir and these
were all gods of thinking about physics
and Computing so I I I I I yelled at the
whole computer industry being based on
uh a fiction Metropolis you know
programmers frolicking the garden while
somebody moves levers in the basement
there's a complete parallel history of
um
uh Maxwell the boltzman to zillard to
um landower to Bennett and most people
won't know most of these names but this
whole parallel history thinking deeply
about how computation and physics relate
so
um I was collaborating with that whole
group of people
and then
you know at MIT I was in this high
traffic environment I wasn't deeply
inspired to think about better ways to
detect shoplifting tags but you know
stumbled across companies that needed
help with that and was thinking about it
and then I realized those two worlds
intersected and we could use the failed
approach for the shoplifting tags to
make
um early Quantum Computing algorithms